afternoon session so we're very happy to
have bana here so bana was
actually a woman in theory stream the
first time 2008 when we started
and she came back 2010 so she was
student here twice and four years ago
she spoke first time
at harvard and she had such good times
so she's she's coming back and
[Laughter]
giving a talk here today
so bana started off as a researcher at
att shannon labs and then since then she
has made a sequence of career moves and
won many
academic awards so right now she's a
professor at ucsd with the dtool as a
faculty member here at berkeley so
without
further ado let's hear about edit this
okay thank you lisa
yeah i like women in theory so much that
i keep coming back and i hope hopefully
it will it will continue and i will
be here again and again in the in future
okay
uh
so today i'm going to talk about
sublinear time algorithms for edit
distance
so why sublinear time
well the data is massive it's time
consuming to access the entire data
there are maybe other computational
constraints as well time is definitely
one constraint but the other constraints
could be space
generally we had
we always wanted to have fast algorithms
and in first algorithms linear term
algorithms are generally considered as
gold standard but given
the massive size of data and other
computational constraints involved we
might need sub-linear time so that's one
expect and the other aspect could be the
data is complex so you may not even if
you have your computational resources
available it may not be you may not have
access to the data there may be other
policy constraints like privacy so you
might just have
only get a snapshot of data and you have
to make your inference based on the
snapshot of the data
well as shafi was
saying
that for any theory questions she like
to have a story so for some linear term
algorithms i don't know what story to
tell but let me let me tell you my
encounter with sublinear term algorithms
in real life
so i moved to i
as lisa was saying i made a few carrier
moves and they moved to this beautiful
city of san diego last year
and i bought a house there uh
it seemed like everything was going fine
so this this picture here is a
picture of plumbing system in the house
okay so it looks very complicated right
so
when we bought the house within one week
i saw there were some visual changes
happening on my floor so the floors are
not looking normal like it's like
budging up like it was bending and
things like that
i realized like okay so after some
research like we realized that there is
some moisture sticking in somewhere
there is some water leak and now when
there is a water leak
uh
plumbing system right you have to look
into the plumbing system it's a house
it's a plumbing system it's not like
massive data
but it's complicated and you cannot
really access even if you have time like
i had all the time at that point like my
house is like lower has to be ripped up
so i wanted to spend the time to
find the source of the problem but you
cannot really look into the plumbing
system even if you have all the time
there are it's complicated so what you
can do you can do random
you can do sampling right there are few
places where you can sample beneath the
sink in the toilet or whatever like in
water heater and so on so you have
sample access
to your plumbing system and from that
you have to make an influence and often
the inference and approximate even the
expert plumbers they will go through
rounds and after that they will be able
to resolve the situation so it's very
much like why we need sub linear why we
have to deal with sub-linear time
algorithms like it's complicated like
data is complex
you may have even if you have like you
only have random we only have sample
access to the data you may need adaptive
rounds
uh you will only get approximate view
because getting exact answer could be
just impossible
and there is often the algorithms that
we encounter in sublinear algorithms are
randomized in nature
and there is two viewpoints query
complexity versus running time so what
is very complexity is the number of
probes that you have to do um
in your data so that's the number of
queries and the running time is
obviously you have a sample but then you
have to
sample size is not the end of the word
right you with the sample for example
you have to process it and then you have
to make the inference so that's your
running time so there are two things
query complexity versus running time
when you are dealing with subject
algorithms
it of course has a long history
perhaps of linear time algorithm was
first studied under the umbrella
property testing in property testing
framework so it was in 90s
so in property testing and ask the
question does your data belong to a
hypothesis class or or is it very far
away from it so that's property testing
so an example will be that you are given
a graph g on n vertices and you want to
decide if g is bipartite or g cannot be
made by apartheid even after removing
like
large and arbitrary subsets of data
maybe arbitrary subset of edges okay so
even if you remove epsilon fraction of
all the edges
the your graph will not be very very
tight so you want to distinguish between
these two extreme cases
it has a very rich history starting from
late 90s
um yeah so that's property testing
tolerant testing is more like
approximation algorithms so here you are
saying even if your data does not belong
to a hypothesis class you want to
estimate the distance of your data to
the hypothesis class and you want to
want to estimate this as well as
possible but obviously exactly
computation is not possible so
you are trying to know whether your data
is within
is at most the distance is at most steep
or is above some approximation factor c
times t
so that's stolen in testing it provides
tradeoffs with approximation factor and
query complexity uh tolerant testing has
also been studied for quite some time
now but it's less less well understood
than property testing
so linear time it also appears in other
settings like streaming
sketching so in streaming the goal is
storage it's not running time
you want to have sublinear space and the
data is coming in a streaming fashion in
an online fashion but obviously
sublinear space is also
closely connected to sublinear time if
you if you have a space complexity which
is
say polylog then obviously like unless
you are doing exponential operations on
that you will also have some linear time
dynamic algorithms in dynamic algorithms
is not
sub linear time as a whole but you want
to keep what is dynamically confidence
is like your input is going through
changes and you want to keep your output
updated at all points and in that case
what is your goal is to keep your
update times of linear so you want some
linear update time even though you have
the space and everything to store your
data so that's dynamic algorithms there
is communication complexity where you
want want to have sub-linear
communication um rather than and those
are all all of these are
connected in some sense like there are a
lot of a lot of com commonalities among
all these models
so today we are going to look at edit
distance
what is edit distance is a very basic
measure
of distance among sequences so it
computes the minimum number of character
insertion deletions
or substitutions to convert x to y so
here you can see an example like
in this example
if you
delete this b then this a b a b they all
match here you can do a substitution
here you can do a substitution and after
that you can delete this b from y so
with this one two deletions and two
substitutions so with a edit of four you
can convert x to y so that's the edit
distance between x and y
it's a very fundamental measure of
sequence similarity it has a lot of
applications in bioinformatics in
natural language processing and so on in
computational biology the main distance
measure that people use is edit distance
and it's much more versatile than
hamming distance where hamming distance
allows only for substitutions edit
distance allows for insertion deletions
as well and that also makes it more
complex for example in the same
instance if you had computed hamming
distance it would have given you
12 errors compared to edit distance
because here you can just
delete this a and you can match
everything but hamming distance does not
allow that okay so even if there is just
one
deletion that will make the two strings
look same but in that case hamming
distance might have to i will say that
the number of errors is like
linear in the string size
computing edit distance it's the
folklore algorithm is ordered in square
which you have all studied in your
undergraduate algorithms class it's one
of the basic dynamic programming
algorithm so in the dynamic you have a n
squared dynamic programming table that
you are trying to fill up
you have your two strings the first
string one on the top and the second
string vertically here
and every instance here this x y box is
actually encoding the edit distance
between the prefix
um of length x in capital x and length y
and capital y
so this blah this box is computing the
distance of the prefix 0 to x here and
prefix 0 to y here and how can you
compute the distance here well like
if you know the edit distance and of
these three boxes
if you know the edit distance here
then you can um
just by like so you have the edit
distance for x minus 1 to y minus 1 then
you can do a like just move move along
the same and consider the next character
like x character and the white character
so that might be one way
or you can delete the
symbol x here
and you move here or you can delete the
this symbol here and you move here okay
so in this these two directions you are
considering deletion so you will be
paying a cost of one
here you can i if the symbols match you
won't be paying anything but if there is
a mismatch you are basically doing a
substitution so diagonal edges are for
substitution and this horizontal edge
and vertical edges are for deletion
so whenever you have to take a
horizontal or vertical edge you have to
pay one because you are deleting
something
and during the diagonal edges it could
be either one or zero based on whether
the characters match or not
so what is the time complexity here like
you are filling up a n square table for
filling up every every box here you have
to look at three adjacent boxes so
constant time so overall it will take
off quadratic
so that's the folklore algorithm and in
fact
uh
there is no truly sub quadratic complex
if there is a truly sub quadratic
complexity algorithm for edited distance
this will violate the strong exponential
time hypothesis
so the strong exponential hypothesis
roughly speaking says like if you have a
satisfiability problem what um
whatever you can do by exhaustive search
that's the best possible
okay so if you assume that's to be true
then there does not exist any truly sub
quadratic algorithm for data distance
yes
to obs
and this is one of the killer stone in
my opinion in fine grain complexity so
find and complexity tries to classify
problems in polynomial time and here
it's like a
it's such a basic polynomial to ml what
is quadratic terminal got when you are
connecting this quadratic time algorithm
with satisfiability which was very
surprising and
that's kind of one of the nicest results
in my opinion in private
so if you assume the strong exponential
and hypothesis then
quadratic is the best you can do and
there is a long line of work on hand but
you want to do better and there is a
long line of work on approximation
algorithm so exactly you cannot do
better than
quadratic so what can you do in
approximation
allowing approximations
and typical holy grail here is to get a
near linear time algorithm so there's a
lot of developments in the last
few years sorry this mask is like
yeah so so
it's not comfortable at all to talk over
this mask
okay so there has been a lot of
developments in recent years on
developing nearly linear time
approximation algorithms for at the
distance on the current best is a
constant factor approximation algorithm
in near linear time
for added distance approximation
but here we are not going to talk about
linear time because sometimes that's
generally the holy grail but sometimes
the holy grail is not
fast enough and here our favorite
application is by informatics because
like dna string could be really long
and even before you start
a little comparison it may be useful to
know if two dna sequences are roughly
similar very fast and that requests of
linear time also it might happen that
there are many pairs of dna sequences
that may need to be compared and if you
know pairwise distance is somehow small
we want to compute it exactly instead of
linear time so there could be two
situations here one is like you have
huge dna sequences you want to really
process them first so that's kind of the
basic inclusion between sub-linear time
and the other could be like you have a
large database of dna sequences you want
to do all pair-based comparisons but
obviously you won't only want to do
comparisons if the distance is small so
in this guy in this kind of situation
maybe if you know the pairwise distance
is small after that you want to compute
it exactly in sublinear time
so what is the model that we are going
to study so this is this is in the
framework of tolerant testing
so we are saying that we have random
access we are given these two strings x
and y
ah we have two parameters k and k prime
k is small k prime is the big so if your
edit distance between you are given
these two strings x and y if the added
distance between x and y is less than k
less than equal to k you want to answer
yes okay and if the edit distance
between x and y is greater than k prime
then you want to answer you
and in this region in this gray region
you don't care what you answer you can
answer either yes or no
so that's the gap at the distance
version and the
tolerance testing version of edit
distance
so any answer allowed in the gray region
but otherwise here you always want to
say yes here you always want to say no
and you have random access
to x and y what we are going to give is
a
randomized algorithm okay so it's going
to be a monte carlo randomized algorithm
for this gap at a distance problem
so let's first look at having distance
and having distance what would you do
for
this kind of gap hamming distance
problem
well you can just simple simply sample
uniformly at random so if you if you are
trying to distinguish between k versus
constant times k then you can uniformly
random sample at a rate of log n over k
then you can apply sure enough bound and
you can
distinguish between these two cases
pretty easily okay
but for
edit distance this kind of uniform
random sampling really cannot
distinguish
like there are strings where there could
be two edits versus there are strings
that
where there could be n edits and this
uniform random sampling won't be able to
distinguish it for example like here is
one example
where you have two strings everything is
different so the edit distance is n
you do random sampling right you sample
something also in the random sampling if
whatever you want to do it the that even
in the sample if you compute the
distance is going to be really large
right
in the second case here
what is the edit distance you can just
delete this h and delete uh delete this
g and then everything matches right the
edit distance is two but if i'm doing
random samples i'll probably sample here
sample here sample here and then i won't
see any any any matches there say the
edit distance in the sample will be also
large
so so we are basically on on the sample
view both of these strings will look
same
so uniform random sampling is not going
to work at all for a distance whereas
it's
for having distance is just like a
simple uniform random
so this gap at a distance has also been
studied quite extensively so it's first
studied in
2003 it's this was the property testing
framework where you want to know whether
the edit distance is below k
or if not whether the distance is very
close to n
so that was the version that was studied
in 2003
so k prime is omega n in this situation
in 2009
the proper gap edit distance version was
studied and you don't have to look into
these complicated terms but there were
some results here i will show you in a
graph
how this results compare
then we had a sequence of results in
2019
we have um
so this one requires k prime to be omega
n
this one works well if the k prime is
large but it doesn't need to be omega n
here it was a lot of restrictions this
restrictions was removed here but still
k frame needs to be large in order these
complexity to be
sublinear
in these two cases we actually handle
this one is efficient for small k as you
can see there is a polynomial dependency
on k here in the running time and that's
why
this this works well
if the if k is small
otherwise this could be
otherwise this could be better
and then this polynomial dependency on k
was not satisfactory so the subsequent
work reduced the polynomial dependency
on k
that's that was the scenario for 2003 to
2020 so let's look at look into a graph
like how all these results compare so on
the y-axis we have
uh
running time it's on the log scale and
on the x axis we have the value of k
again in the log scale
by the way if you look at here
the very first result is a linear time
algorithm from
19 it should be 1998. so from 1998 there
is a linear term algorithm so you can
think about this as a baseline so this
does not look like a dynamic programming
algorithm that i described before
because the dynamic programming
algorithm would have a running time of n
square
here you are seeing a running time of n
plus k square so in a minute i will tell
you about this l chord
but think about that as a baseline
so that baseline will look like this
right like after square root of n so up
to k being square root of n
then you have like linear time
so that's your linear time here
k square root of n because you have n
plus k square
then 2003 work which is on the property
testing framework is basically a dot
here
because your k is like your
okay so let me let me explain this plot
once again so here we are trying to plot
gap at a distance but what is k prime we
are taking a particular value of k prime
here we are using k square
so we are trying to distinguish whether
every distance is below k or it's above
k square
if it's above k square we know that this
2003 work requires k square to be omega
n so k square root of n
in this case square root of n you have
it here so it's like it gives your
running time of 10 to the one fourth
so that's your 2003 paper
then the 2009 paper it essentially shows
you how that
particular complexity will show up when
you are trying to distinguish k versus k
square but as you can see here like if
your k is more than n to the one third
then it gives you a sub linear time
running time okay so at k equal to n to
the one third it goes to linear time
that was the status till 2009
then this was our first work in 2019
where
we give sub linear time when k is
strictly below into the one third
so it was good for small k but still
there was this point at 10 to the one
third when it was linear
so that was 2019
and then
this is this is this work that i'm going
to describe today this is not the state
of the art so this is 2020. so in 2020
we improved this so now as you can see
this is the first work in fact where you
can get entities of linear time
algorithm for the entire region so up to
this point you will follow then this
green work like our work and then you
will follow the 2009 work then you can
get a sub linear time for the full
return obviously this is for k versus k
square and you will see a different
tradeoff if it's not
k squared by something else
this is to show you that even for basic
problem like edit distance like how
little we'll know right like so it's
very recent work but still this picture
should tell you that this is not the
complete story that story
needs to be completed
this was for k square but k versus k to
the 1.5 if you do this this is the plot
you will get but here as you can see
there is a point here which is not sub
linear like even wheat all these
how many colors four colors
four five colors here
okay
so maybe we should concentrate on k
versus k square so for k versus k square
at least by 2020 we had a sub linear
time algorithm for edit distance in the
full vijay
now after 2020 there are two main
questions here so why we were not
getting
sub linear time for the entire region
because of this there was this
polynomial dependency on k so we are
reducing the first term from n we are
getting n over k and over k prime over k
but there was this polynomial dependency
on k that's why these all these results
were for low degree of edit distance
okay
so there was this question can we remove
the polynomial dependency on k and
indeed we can do that this is a very new
result of ours which is under
submissions where we can show that it's
polynomial dependency and k is not
required
which means that the for the full regime
until unless like k is
log n or things like that
then you will get a sub linear time
algorithm
and also we can show that the bound that
we get is
optimal for non-adaptive algorithm what
is non-adaptive algorithm one second
non-adaptive is where you are doing this
random sampling in one shot
sometimes doing random sampling in one
shot is not good so you have to do a few
rounds in that that case it becomes an
adductive algorithm
non-adaptive algorithm as you can see
it's less powerful than adaptive
algorithms but obviously if you can do
some something with non-adaptive
sampling it could be like much more
practical much much easier
so that's our very recent results i'm
not going to talk about this today and
there is another work
by other set of authors which appeared
in stock 2022
where okay so there is this other
question like the question is
we didn't have any lower bounds it's
quite possible that for edit distance
whatever with the sample complexity for
hamming distance
that's the same bound for edit distance
as well
right so the question was can we match
the hamming distance bound
uh for
games
for edit distance
and this work showed that for small
region for small regime of k that's
indeed true
but they had even higher dependency of
polynomial dependency on k and they had
this some other terms as well
so it's not that this holds for the
entire region but for a smaller regime
of k
okay
okay so with all these works this is how
the picture looks like so let me explain
this picture a little bit
you have seen these plots
this is 2003
this is well i was saying 2009 2009 by
12 whatever so this was this was this
2009 work 12 i think is the general
version
then this was our work in 2019 this is
2020.
there was some other paper which also
appeared in 2020 but um
well nothing too uh
the dependency was worse
this is the stock 2022 paper which is
for the smallest time small small
distance regime it matches hamming
distance like up to here up to here it
matches having distance after that
it becomes large okay so if it's n is
less than k is less than n to the one
tenth into the 0.1
then it's optimal but after that it's
not
our result is here this is a recent
result
so this achieves uh
some linear time over the full regime
and this is optimal for non-adaptive
algorithms okay so this is the state
right now
for gap at distance
obviously still there are a lot of
open venues here
the main question is whether you can
draw this line like this
for an adaptive element oh by the way
this algorithm is adapted it has to be
adaptive because this is your lower
bound for non-adaptive algorithm so this
is adaptive
but it stops here after that we don't
know so whether this should go down like
this in fact we know that this is this
point we know is optimal
so we know this point is optimal
we know up to this point is optimal we
don't know anything in here for adaptive
algorithms for non-adaptive we know this
is optimum
so this is the overall picture for
gap at the distance k versus k square
this is just to show you even for basic
problem like edit distance how little is
known in the sub linear time
vijay okay
so let me now tell you a little bit
about
this this result is from 2020. this is
not the state of there is a question
here oh yeah um i'm just curious because
the
algorithm for hamming yourself was not
adaptive right so how does the
the stock 2022 results compared to the
like is that
how is the right type of saying is it
like a coincidence or
[Music]
very simple sampling algorithm sample at
a rate of one over k square yeah right
so sample complexity will be an overkill
square with a lot of work and they
manage to reach in a vertical square
with adaptive algorithm but only for
like when k is less than n to be 0.1
which is a showing that this is a
hardware problem right and but also
showing the state of the art like like
for even for some linear time for basic
problems this video
is changed
yes because they have
these two terms like
they have n over k square but then they
have this entity 0.8 and they have ktd 4
right like you need to know where this
term dominates that's where it will
match the having distance bound and if
you just compare this and this this and
this it turns out to be into the 0.1
okay
there is no lower bound node except for
like we have this lower bound for
non-adaptive algorithms uh
yeah but even for k times k versus
constant gain we do not know whether we
can do it in an average time
problem yeah that's that's the stage yes
okay so here we are going to learn about
the k versus k squared in the end of
interval k plus case but this is the
reason i chose this first of all like i
have my slides ready for this one and
the other ones is like very recent
results i didn't have the slides ready
for it but more more than that like
uh this is the first result which at
least allowed us to get some linear time
algorithm for k versus k square
in the entire region okay
and
this k square in some sense like
the result previous to that had a k cube
dependency whereas if you look at the
linear time algorithm by vishkin and
landau it had a running time of n plus k
square so we are going into the sub
linear region but we really do not want
to pay
more and more in polynomial dependency
on k so we wanted to fix that and this
algorithm kind of fixes that so at least
it doesn't blow up the polynomial
dependency on k beyond k square and it
still gets us a linear time component in
the first part okay so those are the two
features that
this result
which i thought is next
okay so for that let's start with the
algorithm for london vishkin from 1998.
so here we want to test whether edit
distance between x and y is less than k
and the running time we are targeting is
order of n plus k square
okay so which means like if k is less
than equal to square root of n then we
will get a linear time algorithm for
edit distance
obviously k is large you know that you
have a lower bound from strong
exponential hypothesis then this
algorithm cannot give you anything
better than quadratic
so how does the algorithm work you are
trying to fill up a dynamic programming
table still but you will be filling it
up in a greedy way rather than doing the
dynamic programming way so what you do
you start with
is you start with zero here and you try
to match this is your if everything had
matched right if the string x and string
y were the same then what would have
happened in the dynamic programming like
you would have just
followed these main diagonal and you
would have reached the lower end point
and your edit distance would have been
zero
so that's what we will try to do we'll
try to see how far can i go with a value
of zero
okay so you you try to do that and this
is how far you can go with a value of
zero
after that you try to match this b with
a and there is a mismatch so no matter
what you do have to pay or edit cost
there it could be substitution it could
be insertion it could be deletion you do
not know
but this is how far you can go with cos
zero and after that you have to pay a
cost of one
okay so this means you're substituting
this means you are deleting
deleting which one this means you are
deleting
deleting here and this means you are
deleting over here so either you are you
are doing the deletions or this is
substitution but you have to pay a cost
of one
okay so now you have to consider three
diagonals because there is a possibility
of moving forward either along the main
diagonal or along these two diagonals
right now we will see how far can i go
with the value of one
okay so this is how far we can go with
the value of one because if you start
from here this b and b matches then a
and a matches this b and b matches this
a and a matches but if you try to match
b with a you get stuck
okay so this is how far you can go
along these diagonals and here you just
have mismatch right away you make you
get a mismatch right away so you cannot
go much further here but along these two
diagonals you can go up to this much
so you know that in all these points
like
so at every point we are trying to
compute that for every value of i
between 0 to k we are trying to compute
the farthest i valued cell on each
diagonal
can i have a value of 1 in in this
diagonal or in this diagonal
no right
because if you didn't have any edits you
will follow the main diagonal if you
have edits within plus minus one you can
you will follow either this or this two
neighboring diagonal but if you have to
travel to the diagonal on the on the
left or diagonal on the right the number
of edits has to be at least two
so you do not have any points of value
zero or one in the in any any diagonal
beyond these three diagonals
so after you have computed
you have after you have come to this
point then you know at this here you
have to pay at least two
how do you get a 2 here that you will
follow 0 here then we'll come to 1 here
we'll follow 1 here then we'll pay a
deletion and you will come here with the
2. so this is how far you can go in the
main diagonal with the value of 2
and then you can go here with 2 with
substituting here substituting 2 or
being another insertion deletion cost
you can reach these two new diagonals
with a value of 2.
so this is how you will proceed
so this is where you get stuck with 2
then you will compute okay this is where
you have to start with three now you
have seven diagonals to consider and
when you're considering the value of
three you reach this point as soon as
you reach this point you know there is a
path that you have reached and that
gives you the added distance okay so
this is the part if you follow the edit
distance between this two string is
three and then and if you follow this
path then you will get the edits as well
which is needed to compute
so why is the running time
n plus k square so let's explain the k
square first
uh
so how many diagonals do we have to
consider here if eddy distance is
bounded by k there could be at most k
diagonals on the on the right k
diagonals on the left and the main
diagonal so you have to consider at most
two k plus one diagonals
right on these diagonals how many times
if you think that computing these
lines where everything matches takes you
order of one time constant time then how
many times you have you will get stuck
like at most k times right in each of
these diagonals so there will be k break
points in each of these diagonals there
are two k plus one such diagonals so
what all you will be paying k square
time
so that's where the k square time is
coming in the running time
and now how do you compute
how far like here what what are you
trying to compute you are saying hey i'm
starting from this a and a how far can i
go without any
mismatches
this is known as longest common
extension query or in short these are
called lc queries so what landau and
viskin showed in 1998 that you can do a
linear preprocessing of your sequences
and you can answer this lce queries in
constant time
okay so that's why you have the order n
time this is for preprocessing so that
answering lc queries requires order one
time and then you have to cast klc
queries at most for 2k plus one
diagonals and that gives you
the case quality
it's a very nice algorithm like you are
still filling up a dynamic programming
table that you are filling up in a
greedy way and that helps you to bound
the complexity in terms of number of
edits rather than just n square
um why are you playing being the n only
once even though there's k diagonals
why we are playing n only once in the
pre-processing
so we are doing a pre-processing it's
done using suffix trees okay where you
are processing the strings x and y
together and you are
keeping enough information such that
when you have to ask this point like hey
from index three and index
okay and that's three and three here how
far we can go we can look at the
pre-processed information and you can
answer that okay i can go up to here in
constant time
okay so that's why the pre-processing is
taking care of this lc queries being
done in constant time so p processing
requires order n time and then it's all
about lc queries how many lc queries you
are asking
so that was 1998
so in 2019 like the sub linear time
algorithm the first sub linear term
algorithm that we came up with
we utilized this lambda viscon algorithm
but instead of computing exact lc
queries
we we were we tried to compute
approximate lc queries okay so
previously we were saying
if we look at here we are asking how far
can i go without any mismatch
now we want to reduce the time
complexity for this lc query somehow now
we are saying hey let's instead of going
considering exact matches let's consider
approximate match
let's ask this question from this point
how far can i go say maybe with k
mismatches
okay so that's approximate and c query
so that was our main idea at that point
like hey let's use the land of vishkin
algorithm but now i will allow
less than k
i will allow mismatches for lc query
okay so at most k mismatches parallel
sequence so if i do that now i do not
get stuck over here
i can move a little bit beyond that
because i'm allowing more mismatches and
so on but then i will just compute
according to landau and bishken
so i'm just doing same landau and
vishkin but i'm just allowing mismatches
in the lc queries and now i can finish
it off with two
edits
instead of three
so obviously as you can see see like if
the true edit distance is below k
here you are just underestimating right
because you are doing you are just
moving much you can move much further
than what you had done if you had used
exact lc queries so the es instances
will stay yes if edit distance true edit
distance was below k you are still going
to answer yes
now the question is
is that it just plug how much
underestimation we are doing here
okay
so how many branches how many such green
branches can be there until you reach
this point there could be at most like
if the number of branches is more than k
you are anyway going to say no
right you know that the distance is more
than k
so the number of branches here even if
you if you are considering yes instances
that then there could be at most k such
green segments
okay in each of the green segments you
are allowed to
have k mismatches at most k mismatches
so if you are following this part then
therefore the added distance you haven't
witnessed that the edit distance between
these two sequences cannot be more than
k square
so if you're saying yes then you know
that the distance has to be below k
square
okay so that handles both cases so yes
instance yes you are going to say yes
but if the edit distance is above k
square you are not going to say yes
like less than
square root k mismatches for lcr you
would get um k versus k to the 1.5
exactly
so now the question is obviously like
how can i implement these how can i
implement this approximate lc queries
with
low fuel quality complexity
but if you look at naive implementation
then what can happen that you have to
look if which band are you looking here
you are looking at a band of 2k plus one
diagonals right so overall you are
trying to fill up an area of dynamic
programming which can have a size of n k
n times k
and since you are trying you are
forgetting like
you you can have up to k mismatches here
so you have to somehow sample at a rate
of 1 over k
right like to ha after you don't want to
go beyond kv's matches so you'll be
sampling at a rate of letter 1 over k
but if that if you just pull those 2 in
then you have you may need to look at nk
cells in the dp table and if you are
sampling at a rate of 1 over k this will
basically give you linear time which
will not help much so the question is
how can i reduce this kind of global
sampling like i do not want to do
global sampling in this naive way like
this in case of at a rate of whatever k
so is there a way to reduce the amount
of global sampling so what we showed in
the 2019 paper
that if you spend some local time
whenever you are getting stuck
if you spend
if you look at in locality of order k
around everything
around each of these lc queries
then a global sampling rate of in a
total global sampling of n over k is
enough
okay so i'm not going to the details of
that algorithm
but what we are doing we are spending
some local time around hlc query to
overcome the
global sampling of order of n to reduce
it to order of n 2 in in over k
then what would be the
sample complexity like you are spending
k time par l c query as we saw the
number of lc queries could be k square
so that's why you get a k cube
time complexity over here okay so you're
spending order of k time it's both query
complexity and complexity in this
situation so you're spending order of k
times park lc query but it's because you
are spending order of k time you can
actually reduce the global sampling rate
from n to n over k
anyway so that gives you n over k plus k
cube time
and this k q was not satisfactory
because in lambda which can you get k
square so like yes i'm reducing
on the first term but this k cube term
was unsatisfactory
so the main goal of our 2020 paper was
to reduce these k cube terms so that it
leaves to match it the lander which can
on the second term while keeping itself
linear in the first
so how do we do that
what do you do have to do for that like
here we are spending
we have k square lc queries part lc is
query we are spending order of k time if
somehow i can reduce the number of lc
queries to order of k
then even if i'm spending k time
parallel c query i will get k square in
that term and i will still be suppose
and still be
having this n over k time so our goal
was to reduce the number of lc query
from k squared to order of k
so how do we do did that
like previously what we were doing so we
we are still allowing approximately
query okay so previously we got stuck
here then we are initiating three
diagonals
one two three and then three different
positions
now what we are going to do we are going
to do some synchronization so here i am
going to say hey i am not i will look at
the same position why even if i'm stuck
here i will actually move here
i'm synchronizing
okay so i will i so that's what i'm
going to do i'm going to synchronize
here and i will start my lc query from
the same point
in
x
so i'll start my lc queries all over
here and i will again do approximate lc
queries
but here like
i might have different positions from
where i would have started in the
previous cases the lc queries here again
i'm synchronizing and i'm starting from
here
it might not look useful at this moment
like hey yes i'm synchronizing but what
does it give me but anyway so that's
what we are doing is synchronizing in y
and we are considering the lc queries
from
that point one word and now it
matches here and we
again output whatever value we have to
here
the correctness word
again how many how many segments of
these we can have
like okay
in each of this segment we are allowing
okay so for the es instance if the edit
distance was really less than k
right in this case what is happening
previously i was starting the lca query
over here and here i'm just moving even
down like i am basically i'm even moving
more forward so i'm not going to
say
in the es instance i'm not going to say
no right yes instance states yes and the
question is like
can i if the number of edits is too much
over k square can i say no can i say yes
even in that situation like what is
happening here due to synchronization
previously whatever wherever my lcq
errors were only coming from these
segments instead of being exact i was
allowing k errors right
now because of this shift
there could be some errors due to the
shift as well because of the
synchronization but how much that error
could be like at every point i get stuck
i can move like k diagonals here and
there
right so you might add a shift error of
order of k
whenever you are getting stuck
and how many times will you get stuck
you will get stuck at most state times
so the shift errors will be about order
of k square
so yes there will be substitution areas
of about k square and there will be
shift errors but shift errors is also
about order of k square
so within a constant factor you would
you you were fine
so
if you're saying yes the distance has to
be below k square
so the correctness is fine
now the question is how does it help us
to
reduce the time complexity because of
this synchronization
well so for here
if you look at here right like you have
uh synchronized you are in the same
position at y
right but still if you're thinking in
this way there might be klc queries that
you have to ask
right from the same position y but still
there could be klc queries that you have
to ask
now
the nice trick over here is to
exploit periodicity in strings
the periodic periodicity in the strings
is saying
if i can slide along this multiple
diagonals here then there must be some
structure in your string right like if i
am looking at x here
sliding along multiple diagonals means i
am using this diagonal and sliding this
is matching over here
this diagonal if i am sliding this is
matching over here this diagonal if i'm
sliding this is matching over here
right which means my string y
is periodic
and that also means like yes like my
string x is also periodic
so if it indeed happens there are
multiple diagonals through which i can
slide
both x and y must be periodic
okay so this is the inside that we had
and
another interesting observation that we
saw that
well yes like
if there are multiple diagonals that we
want to have want to consider
that is multiple lc queries then it's
the strings are periodic
so maybe i don't check each of these
diagonals separately but i just checked
for periodicity instead
and another observation that we had that
when the periodicity breaks
then only there could be only one
diagonal
where you won't see an error it's
possible there is one diagonal where you
won't see an error but in all other
diagonals you will see an error
okay so that means all those are the
diagonals you can discard and then there
you are left with just one lc query
so that's the
main idea
just to show you a little bit more of
that same concept of periodicity so your
x is periodic if if x is matching over
multiple diagonals then y is periodic as
well okay so there could be obviously
there could be many diagonals where it
can match
but now if you see a mismatch anywhere
here like it was periodic but it was
suddenly suddenly there is a mismatch
over here
then as you try to compare the other
diagonals they will also start making
mistakes over on that point
okay so which means in all diagonals you
will find an error when the periodicity
breaks
so basically this is saying that you
don't really have to check for
every k diagonals you just check for
periodicity
and when the periodicity breaks there
could be at most one diagonal and why
there could be at most one diagonal
essentially it could happen that this
diagonal where the periodicity broke it
also broke here it also broke here
so only this diagonal survived it didn't
make a mistake but everywhere else there
will be a mistake
okay
so just check for periodicity and this
can be done using sampling of n over k
sampling rate
and once the periodic periodicity breaks
spend order k time
to find the surviving diagonal and on
the surviving diagonal as the lca query
so overall how many lc queries then you
ask like for every synchronization step
here
you did the periodicity check right
somewhere periodicity broke you know
that everything works except for one
diagonal here everything had error
forget about those diagonals then you
just have one surviving diagonal on that
you ask a lcd query so every time you're
stuck you are asking one lc query you
can get stuck at most k times for every
every time you are getting stuck you're
spending order of k time right so
overall you have k square and this
global sampling rate is giving you n
over k
so that's kind of the basic idea of how
you get n over k plus k square time
and you can distinguish k versus k
square
questions
how are you checking for diagonal breaks
how are you checking so you check for
periodicity okay so you're checking
quick sampling
then you're sam sampling over here and
you are sampling over the same positions
over here you are checking whether the
periodicity is minted at some point
periodically if you find a violation
here that this is violating at this
point
you go to the x all the diagonals you
spend order k time matching
like okay so main diagonal match it here
here for diagonal one diagonal two
diagonal three you will spend order k
time but there is no one position
order okay right so that's why like you
need this order case space around every
time you get stuck
but you are now making one nc query per
search query for such
position so overall it gives you order
of k square
okay so it's not just about k versus k
square you can extend it to k versus any
k prime and in that case like you will
still be doing a synchronization but you
won't do a you won't be doing a
synchronization over like all k
diagonals you will consider the
diagonals in band and you will be doing
synchronization only in band
yeah
so like you will come here previously
you're saying
hey i will do synchronization like i
have one one one here i will do
synchronization here like this now here
i get stuck
two two two here like i will do
synchronization like this but if this
picture should make it clear like here
i'm not doing synchronization overall
i'm doing synchronization here in the
white band in the screen and i'm doing a
synchronization in this wideband i'm
keeping doing the synchronization and so
on so this is just to reduce the amount
of shift error
because as you are doing synchronization
you are paying shift errors you're
paying errors in insertion deletions so
if you're not doing
not synchronizing to completely you are
reducing the amount of shift error and
then you can increase the sample rate to
reduce the number of
errors partial c query
okay so by doing that you can handle k
versus k prime where k prime is less
than k square
okay before i end i just want to say a
little bit about like
okay so these are all about approximate
computation what about exact computation
because in most of the cases in
practical applications you want to know
exact
okay so in this scenario
at least like you have if you think
about this kind of model where you have
many dna sequences but you are allowed
you are anyway going to sequence them
and you are going to store them so if
you think about okay so yeah each of the
dna sequences are coming i'm
pre-processing them and spending linear
time pasteuring to be processed and
after that like i spend linear time
pre-processing the string on the left
hand side string on the right hand side
but then the queries could be paired by
queries
okay so you have the string a string b
have the pre-processed information for
each of them separately in the land of
whisking algorithms the pre-processing
needs to consider both strings together
okay so here i am saying the preprocess
of string separately after this
preprocessing phase you ask pairwise
queries and you have to really return
this various p r y squared is
very fast
in this kind of pre-processing model in
fact what you can show
that
in order of k square time you can get
you can give exact answer
overall like
if you are thinking about theoretical
results
there are
everything like there are theoretical
results which shows any polynomial
preprocessing time is not going to break
the strong exponential time hypothesis
you will still
won't be able to get any sub quadratic
exact algorithm but in practice if k is
small then indeed
reprocessing really helps like with the
very time of order of k square you can
return exact answer
and this is this is a very simple
algorithm that we had like well in
london when vishkin you really need
these two strings to bring the submarine
to preprocess using suffix tree what
instead you can do you can pre-process
the strings using and you can store some
rolling hash functions
okay so once you store the rolling hash
functions this lc queries instead of
having constant time power lc query you
can compare
log n such rolling hash functions and
you can compute these lc queries in
order of log n type
but in this case a preprocessing becomes
separate like you separately pre-process
x separately pre-process y you spend
login times by lc query and then like
you just run land of ishkin like when
you are running lander which can if the
pre-processing phase is done you are
spending at most p square time okay so
with k square log n you can you can
return exact answer
and obviously there are many open
questions here like how you can reduce
uh is this case square time necessary or
like a more practical model will be
where you you have your database where
you have pre-processed all the sequences
but now a new sequence comes which is
not pre-processed so it's like one
sequence pre-process the other is not
and you want to compute the distances
first so there could be other models
which are more practical
anyway so these are open questions like
there could be
many more open questions in this area so
linear time you saw what is the state
like
we at least know
pretty well for non-adaptive algorithms
but for adaptive algorithms the scenario
is still not quite satisfactory
dynamic algorithms in fact nothing is
known in dynamic algorithms for headed
distance beyond some trivial bounds so
everything is open for dynamic
algorithms
uh
there has been a lot of work on
approximation and near never search
nothing is known called added distance
again beyond some trivial bounds
approximation algorithms a lot of works
has been done but still
we do not know whether it's possible for
example to get a one plus epsilon
approximation in sub quadratic time
and obviously when you're stuck with
most cases beyond worst case is
definitely an area where you can explode
your
put your energy in there are some
results there as well known for added
distance computation but still um
there are
big gaps between lower bounds and upper
bounds
and generalization for other sequences
like we are talking about edit distances
really not required to talk about edit
distance you can think about any other
similarity measures you can think about
distances from models rather than
distances from a sequence which is known
as and this this model is specified by
some formal language you call it
language edit distance
and all of these sequence problems
actually
have the slip shift or continued
continuity property like if you display
perturb your input sequence so slightly
then your output is not going to change
much okay so that property is exploited
even if you think about lambda which can
like we're saying hey how far can i go
with zero then what should be the values
in the nearby cells in the dynamic
program it can be just plus one or zero
right so the difference cannot be too
much so that's the continuity property
so almost all algorithms and
when you have better algorithms then
trivial uh whatever you can get by
dynamic programming or exhaustive search
that means to exploit the sleep shifts
property
graph distances
and there is another interesting venue
to consider is like computing over
compressed data so if you are thinking
about sub linear time algorithms if your
data is compressible suppose you have
you compress your data and then what the
compressed data you run a linear time
algorithm but still over the considering
the input size like uncompressed input
size it will be sublinear so what can
you do in that
scenario it could be either lossless
compression or lossy compression we have
some results for lossless compression we
don't have anything for lossy
compression so
that's another area which is very
interesting
for some linear time according to
okay so i think i'm done
i just want to say
about the tcs women workshop that will
happen in stock where srivanki will be
on the panel right and jessica will be
our one of our rising stress speakers
and wordpress had been a raising
staffing speaker for tcs women so as
lisa mentioned like i was so influenced
in my career by coming to women in
theory it's like us for us to say thank
you like this is like
this women in theory has been so
influential in many of like career of
women researchers so mysticious women is
trying to bring more women students
to stock and fox if you haven't heard
about it
like we provide uh scholarships
travel scholarships to women's students
so even if you do not have a paper you
can apply 46 women scholarship and come
to stock
we have we are organized rising star
um workshop like rising stars like
a workshop for
for
graduating students
so that's why where i would be the
attendant and jessica will be there we
have panels and other things we are also
looking for volunteer but if well it's a
great opportunity for
many of you if you want to attend fox
and stock you can look out for these
scholarships okay thank you
we have a particularly short break uh so
we're not going to take any questions
but then um you know there will be
banquet tonight you have questions
please ask banner then
so the plan uh now is it's already three
or five uh 3 15 we plan to have a group
picture just outside um
so don't go far
and uh before
this talk i sent out a link for the
second day
uh
survey so after the panel please just
fill it in it's actually very very
important for us to
to have your feedback so
you stay near here yeah thanks